shame on you
shame on you a chorus of anger from
protesters outside london's court of
appeal as a judge gave the green light
for the first flight of refugees and
migrants to rwanda
rights groups say it includes people who
had escaped war in afghanistan and syria
and being flown more than 6 000
kilometers away will traumatize them
further they've suffered incredibly
they've seen family members killed
they've had torture themselves
they are tired they're at the end of
their tether they're finding detention
incredibly traumatizing and the thought
of a further deportation halfway across
the road is absolutely terrifying for
them
uk prime minister boris johnson says a
deportation strategy will undermine
people smuggling networks and deter
refugees from making dangerous journeys
to britain
the united nations refugee agency hit
back saying rwanda's human rights record
is under scrutiny and the uk is shirking
responsibility this is all wrong this is
all wrong
this
deal
you know it is the foundation of the
right to
asylum that people
that are on a country's territory
especially a country that is a signatory
to the convention and
has the institutions to deal with that
in april home secretary pretty patel
visited gagali to finalize the project
and potentially send tens of thousands
of people there
the deal includes a payment of about 150
million dollars to the rwandan
government
so far this year 10 000 migrants from
refugees made the crossing from mainland
europe to the uk and 28 000 last year
in november 27 people drowned when their
dinghy deflated and many more have had
to be rescued from the channel's busy
shipping lanes
some of those who risked their lives
will leave on the first flight on
tuesday
but there may not be many on it
a series of individual legal challenges
mean only a few of the 130 people
notified will leave
and the government continues to face
pressure from activists rights groups
and unions who insist the move is
unlawful
about manly al jazeera